hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to my game engine
series so last time we took a look at
creating a properties panel
check out the video up there if you
haven't already and today we're going to
be continuing on with the whole
properties panel adventures
more specifically beginning to implement
the ui for all the various
different components that we have in our
game engine at the moment so the first
thing i want to do is actually take a
look at hazel dev
so if we uh if we come on if we come on
over here into hazelnut this is the
development version of hazel that's
available to patrons
uh by the way patreon.com best way to
help support the series and everything
that i'm doing here
um if we look at the properties panel
here obviously it's been expanded quite
a bit
uh you know compared to what what we
have in our kind of humble game engine
series version of hazel
but um this properties panel you know
the idea is we can select anything here
and of course it's going to display
the actual components that we have here
you know we can add components we can
remove components the ui is still kind
of like work in progress but
you can see that it's basically
functional and this is just an example
of what it is we're working towards in
our kind of game engine series
so what we're going to focus on today is
this camera component
so the camera component uh lets us it's
obviously something that we
actually um add to a camera if we were
to play the scene now
you can see that whatever the camera
component contains so like
you know the projection the field of
view you can see i can change actually
while it's running
but all of the stuff that the camera
component actually uh you know controls
is
the in-game camera that we have for our
scene now we've created a scene camera
in our um in our code base so if we look
at
this scene camera class the scene camera
class is i believe what's inside
our our um camera here so we have
a camera component with a scene camera
you know whether or not it's primary
fixed aspect ratio
for like resizing based on the window
size all of that stuff this represents
an actual runtime game camera
and that's what that's what this
component controls so we can change
between perspective orthographic
you can see the ui updates and gives us
like an orthographic size and nuclear
farclip
whereas with perspective we have a
vertical fall as well as like a near
clip and far clip um i guess we didn't
see the far clip text
but anyway this this kind of layout and
this
this ui i guess is what we're going to
be creating today
before we jump into that though i did
mention in my previous video which was
uh
about like the importance of long-term
planning and it was like a hazel
hazel road map essentially that there is
now officially a road map for both the
development version of hazel
as well as this kind of game engine
series version of hazel and by this i
don't mean what's on the screen right
now
i mean let's let's let's show our
amazing
game engine series version of hazel this
right so there is now officially a road
map for this series
if you go to hazel engine.com roadmap
there'll be a link in description below
as well
this is what you'll see right this is
the game engine series progression so
it's got the current goal as well as
what we're currently working on
these are generally in order of of how
we're going to work on them
the stuff within here probably isn't
necessarily strictly in order
but you can see that what we're going to
be uh doing and what we're working on at
the moment is the hazelnut ui
kind of minimum viable product right so
we're trying to create a ui
for hazelnut that is somewhat functional
so that we can create like a bunch of
entities add components to them do all
of that kind of fun stuff
and then once we have that you know
we're going to be focusing on
serializing the scene so that we can
save all the work that we've done
as well as load it and then you know
actually hit play to play the game
that's the idea that's kind of the
progression that we're working towards
because our goal
is of course to create that 2d workflow
and get that up and running
so what what i want to do today is knock
off one of these and as i mentioned
we're going to be doing the camera
component ui
and our goal is to kind of make it as at
least as functional as this stuff here
so without further ado
let's dive in and take a look at how we
can uh
do all of this stuff so what i want to
do
um is first of all if we go into the
scene hierarchy panel let me just
terminate this
um you know we have the if entity has
component transform component we're
going to do the same thing
but we're going to do it for um let's
just get rid of some stuff here
we're going to do this for the camera
component of course so camera components
uh camera we'll get the camera
components
and we'll just get the well there's a
there's actually a bunch of stuff in
here that we want it's not just like the
transform the camera component has
whether or not it's the primary camera
and stuff like that um
so maybe let's just retrieve camera
component like that
and then this so this is basically the
skeleton for what we actually want
now when we start editing this one of
the first choices that we have to make
is whether or not we're a perspective
camera or an orthographic camera
now at the moment we are focusing on 2d
so technically you could say maybe we
don't need a perspective camera if we're
strictly rendering in 2d then there's
no need for perspective because well
there's two dimensions so clearly stuff
further back is not going to be rendered
smaller
however i think i will add support for
this just because we might as well
and i know that some people want to do
maybe some kind of maybe
maybe even if we do deal with 2d quads
maybe we still want
to have them in 3d space and you know
i'll allow for that even though we're
strictly supposed to be doing 2d stuff
so to make that happen what we want is
is kind of like this combo box right to
be able to go between the two
so let's take a look at how we can
implement a combo box inside i am gooey
so there's a control called i am gooey
begin combo
right well this is like the the function
we call to actually start the combo box
we have a label for it um and this will
be our
i guess we'll just call this projection
and then we have a preview value which i
guess is going to be the current
projection
so what we kind of need to do is
basically create a little we can just
use a
const char pointer array here we'll call
this projection
type strings right and then this is just
going to be the two projection types so
perspective
and orthographic orthographic
right we then need to uh actually get
the current projection type of the
camera
now at the moment if we look at our
camera and specifically our scene camera
i don't believe we actually
like that there is no like current
projection type right
so this is something that we need to add
and i think the way that i did this um
in hazel dev was by simply having like
an enum class
uh called like projection type and then
i think i just had like perspective
set to zero and orthographic set to one
so the purpose of this and also the
reason why these numbers actually matter
is because they're actually
we're going to use them as indices into
this array so in other words
zero is going to match perspective so
the first index inside this projection
type strings
and orthographic is going to match index
number one
right so now we've got a way to store
them as an enum right and we can just
um i don't know where we're going to put
this i guess we'll put it as the first
thing
projection type uh and we'll set it
equal to like
i guess all the graphic for now just
because we're
in 2d land but realistically you
probably want for
a game engine like hazel you probably
wanted to be 3d by default
because that's what you would probably
expect people to use um even if they are
making a 2d game nothing
nothing necessarily wrong with
perspective rendering of course
or perspective projection okay so now uh
the next step
is going to be to um see what the
current cameras projection is
and then actually have a uh i guess like
a
a pointer to the projection type so cons
char
current projection now these are
constant pointers so we don't have to
worry about copying them or anything
because they're just pointers
so current projection string current
projection type string
right so what this is going to be is one
of these
right um it's going to be one of these
um
and specifically it's going to be camera
component dot
camera dot get projection type which we
don't have yet
cast to an end so we've got the enum
we're casting it to an end we should get
zero or one and that should correspond
to one of these
and this is what we can feed into here
so we'll say if
this is for whether or not we actually
click on it to expand it
so if it has been started we need to
deal with we
actually need to write some imgui code
to handle uh selection here which we
will do in a minute but first i want to
implement this get
projection type function so this will be
projection type get projection
type const return projection type
and then now obviously this should work
out okay
so um what this should do is
if i just launch this um probably no not
really
any point in launching it just yet but i
will anyway
um what this is going to do
is hopefully when we select the camera
entity because it has a camera component
all right nothing else does
um clip space entity again i don't know
why it's called that but that's also
that's our secondary camera
you can see that it says the
disorthographic and if we click on this
it doesn't actually say anything yet
because we need to populate the list
but you can see that the type is correct
it is in fact orthographic because we
set it to orthographic by default
so what we want to do now is actually
populate it with all the values
so how do we go through all the values
well we basically need to go through all
of these
strings so i i can say four in i equals
zero i is less than two i plus plus
because we know there's just two
project projection types and there
always will be um and in fact i might
call this like well
we'll call this eye um so the first
thing is we need to see what the
currently selected projection type is
uh so is selected i guess
um so in other words is the current one
where it ring
iterating over is that the currently
selected projection type
and the way that we check that obviously
is just by you know these are the same
like the pointers are equal in fact so
we can just say
current projection type string equals
projection
type strings i right so if it's the
selected one
then that will be true then we'll write
if i'm going selectable
uh projection
[Music]
type strings string i'm currently
referencing the height without code
obviously here
um and then this is i it's just a little
bit different so i'm trying to
do all the variable renaming in my head
um so what what a selectable is
is basically a little thing that you can
select so that's like one of the
when we actually hit the drop down menu
and we see all the options there
a selectable is one of the options so
what we're doing here is we're handling
a click on it
so if we click on us we obviously want
to now
select whatever was there right so the
new projection type that's what we're
trying to do here
let me just make sure this is all fine
so
it's selected um
is selected so what is this exactly so
ball selected equals false by default
but that's set to that and
everything else should be okay i'm not
sure why that's not
apparently constant shot construct oh
right sorry
this uh needs to be
projection type string as i right so
it's the current progression type string
a const char
pointer um and then uh so if we have in
fact selected it we just need to change
the current projection type string
to be this
right because we've selected it
and then finally we want to actually
obviously set the projection type on the
camera
so we've got get projection type we'll
also make a set projection type
and it should be fairly easy because
what we want to do is set it to i
essentially because that's the current
index of
perspective or orthographic so to do
that
we can um write the function
so avoid set projection type
now this will again need to potentially
recalculate the matrix and do some other
stuff which we'll
talk about in a minute but this is going
to set the projection type to whatever
it is so projection type type
type okay and then now obviously we need
to cast this
to scene camera projection type just
like that
all right great so we've got that sorted
out now
um and that's obviously if we click on
it uh however we also need to say that
if
um if is selected we want to give it
a default focus so this is important as
well and to be honest i don't remember
exactly what this does
um
[Music]
if it's selected as the default time
yeah so what this do i guess what this
does is it actually shows the default
item as the
as the uh like inside the combo box so
important stuff
all right so we then then we end the
combo box and these are just little ui
things as usual um
but that i think that should be it so
the actual set projection type
function it depends how your camera is
set up
because i think in hazeldev we
recalculate the camera's matrix all the
time
whereas if if you uh obviously if you um
have an actual recalculator projection
function that happens upon setting
orthographic or setting perspective and
stuff you need to call that
so we potentially need to call this
right um but more importantly we need to
actually populate it with
perspective camera uh you know fields
right so we what this ends up looking
like
is a little bit complicated because if
you look at this inside hazeldev
a vertical field of view only applies to
a perspective camera
however if i if i switch to orthographic
i don't suddenly want to throw
throw away that value of 45. i obviously
want to keep it
because if i switch back i expect 45 to
be there not 0
or like some other default value if i
set this to 55 or whatever and i go to
orthographic and then back again i want
it still there
which effectively means that this
component needs to carry
both the orthographic parameters as well
as the perspective parameters that's
kind of expected
now obviously for a games runtime or
whatever you wouldn't need any of this
technically you'd probably only get away
with a matrix and everything's fine
but you know this is the editor and it
needs to be able to have a lot more
information
than the game so what this means is that
we need to
uh inside the camera class and i guess
we can test this out but
i mean this should work at the moment
all we're doing is storing an integer
which represents the current projection
type that we can set to whatever we want
so in other words this should remember
what it is
if we change it to perspective it should
it should be perspective
and then orthographic so this should now
work and obviously we can
we should be able to play around with
this and you know this one's totally
graphic that one's still perspective
but obviously that does nothing at this
point in time which is fine because we
don't really expect it to do anything
we haven't written that code yet but now
when we actually go through this so this
is the combo box
when we actually go through this and we
like want to set things like the
orthographic size we obviously need the
projection parameters as well
so what we'll do first of all is we'll
check to see what the current projection
type is
um this time we don't need to we can use
a switch statement or we can use a
just an if here so we don't need to
obviously pass it to an end here we can
just do scene camera
uh projection type uh perspective
and then we do all of the perspective
stuff right and then
if it's orthographic then we need to
display all of the orthographic
properties
so the orthographic properties
specifically are obviously
um if we just look at the same camera
it's the orthographic size
yeah so it's obviously going to be like
the orthographic size um
and
the near clip and the far clip but we
don't have functions for that
so i'm going to add the functions in now
so the functions shall be
uh sorry i'm a little all over the place
here
still checking in on stream chat and all
that stuff um
so we'll we'll do uh this will be i
guess
get near clip so the good the good news
with the neoclip and the far clip is it
applies to both
um projection uh to both perspective and
orthographic projections
so return near clip um but no
actually i should say that unfortunately
no it doesn't because whilst it does
apply to both
we do need to we didn't we do need to
separate them because it's obviously
very common for orthographic to be like
between negative one and one for example
and then perspective to be between zero
and ten thousand
or like zero point zero point zero 0.01
and 10 000 right so they are completely
different and we would expect them to
you know remain faithful to what they're
supposed to be so get orthographic
near clip and then
get orthographic far clip
so we've got those two and then we
obviously want to have set orthographic
near clip
near clip
and then set orthographic far clip
um all right so uh get us in setters
and let's just uh organize that maybe
like that
so orthographic size orthographic near
clip orthographic far
clip let's display that stuff
so um let's see
uh you know what i'll do probably is
just do
camera equals camera component.camera
just because
i don't want to keep calling camera
component.camera everywhere
like here for example and here
okay so um camera
get orthographic size is what i care
about i'll just quickly write them down
get all the graphic size and then we
obviously have near
clip and far clip
okay so this is pretty simple just i'm
going drag
float i guess
the orthographic size so label again
we'll just say
size labels are currently going to be on
the right because that's how i am gui
works but in the future
we will write some code to make them
like be split up into like two columns
here
um and be like you know with the labels
on the left and the stuff on the right
but just not at the moment that's going
to actually be in our roadmap
in the polish ui pass that we do
eventually
okay so size
is camera uh and the way that you do
this
again again as like you know usually i
end up doing something like floats
um you know ortho size or something
equals
get orthographic size and then this is
what i obviously pass in here so
this becomes uh taking an auto size
um i don't know what the units should be
and then if it if it changes at this
point then i'll just set it
so camera dot set author size
or the graphic size to author size
that's it
and this kind of pattern you follow for
everything else so
um the uh
orthonor ortho far
this obviously near clip
far clip um
set orthographic far clip set
orthographic
near clip orthonia
lots of lots of copying and pasting here
um so this is like near far
to keep the label simple i think that's
it
right so that's basically like that's us
setting the camera correctly
no recalculating is taking place here
which is wrong
but um i think we've got all the ui
sorted so if we click on camera you can
see it looks here it doesn't look the
best
but um you know we should be able to set
the stuff uh it doesn't look like it
actually gets
set uh which is strange
oh okay oh this works why does this work
oh well they're all pointing to the same
thing here that's because i'm a
yeah not enough copying and pasting it
seems i tried my best but
no i'm drinking some pineapple tea here
which is a little odd but it's not too
bad
um all right there we go orthographic
near and far is fine and yeah it's it's
a little bit strange
as to uh why the size is working so if
we set the other graphics
all right because it actually caused
recalculate projection so this is
something that we
you know as a little um i'm not sure if
we want to calculate this
or like recalculate them straight away
um
but uh you know we could just
easily just add recalculate projection
let me just um
i don't like the fact that it's doing
that
but there's no way around it all right
so when we set anything where we
calculate the projection pretty standard
um
including when we actually set the uh
when we actually set the production type
so if we launch this now hopefully our
clipping will also work
and yeah we've basically written a
little camera um ui component system
which is pretty cool so we can edit the
camera stuff
there's the size there's the new clip
and far club you can see it's working
because it's clipping
now if we go to perspective um and then
back again it'll recalculate everything
we won't see that because
there is currently no no perspective
stuff so let's add in the perspective
stuff now
so the perspective stuff how does that
work well
if we go to scene camera basically we
want a copy of this
but for perspective stuff so i'll
conveniently just
edit both both of these at once
perspective except instead of size we
probably want to
like it's it's just the the fog really
um by default
in hazel i'm setting this is the
vertical fault to 45 by default just
because that seems
good and then perspective near and far
um
perspective near and far so zero point
zero zero one i was point zero one
um and perspective far
we'll set to we'll set it to like ten
thousand maybe
i don't know that that does seem like a
lot maybe one thousand
um it doesn't really matter too much
like for now obviously like with
precision
precision and like stuff like that for
you know
various clipping and said fighting
things you might want to tweak that for
depending on the scale of your game and
all that stuff
but again for now it's not going to
matter um
all right so that's the perspective
stuff so now we just want to add a whole
bunch of functions
now because there's going to be a lot of
stuff here i'm going to actually group
both the orthographic and perspective
stuff together right
and again because perspective is
presumably the more used one i'm going
to put this
up here actually so i'm i've copied
these
i'm pasting them here again and then
instead of orthographic size obviously
this becomes
perspective fall um now
we'll say perspective vertical fault so
it'll be nice and
uh you know um detailed here
verbose if you will with our naming
um just because we might want like a
horizontal file function i don't know
this will obviously do set instead and
this will just set
the five i guess we probably also want a
function that can easily
set all of these at once so what i mean
is like it'd be nice to have like a set
perspective
like yeah well actually we've got one
here set autographic so again it'd be
nice to have a set perspective function
that just sets it to whatever we want
for us um
so uh
let's change this to perspective 5
equals 5
and just to be really clear here i might
make sure that's set
to vertical 5. um all right let's just
quickly
get through this stuff
perspective instead of orthographic
everywhere
um and that's probably it to be honest
so
again i'll duplicate this function just
for completeness we'll call it set
perspective
vertical fall near the far clip um and
then this will actually
uh set everything for us so it'll do i
guess
perspective of equals vertical fluff
orthographic no sorry perspective near
equals
near clip perspective
far equals far clip
and then it will recalculate it but the
other thing that it has to actually do
by the way is make sure that our
projection type is set to perspective
right and this has to set it to
orthographic because now when we
recalculate things like we did before we
need to actually see what it is
so if the projection type
equals perspective we'll do one thing
else
there's only two types so it doesn't we
don't really need to see this
but uh how did i do it in hazel that did
i actually have an explicit check
yeah i actually had like a switch
statement okay whatever
um let's just do uh
else what one else we've only got two
anyway so else we'll do the orthographic
right
but if it is if it is um perspective
then we basically just want to set
projection
equal to glm perspective
uh i believe and then fog with height so
this just does the aspect ratio for us i
think
which i guess we don't we might not need
because that viewport size sets the
aspect ratio so actually we don't want
perspective for we just want perspective
yeah so this this this takes in the
field of view which is the fov
and then we have the aspect which is
aspect ratio which is the
um our screen uh aspect ratio
of our viewport then near and far which
is just perspective
near
and perspective far okay
that that should be it actually um so
now if we hit f5
oh we haven't added ui for any of this
my bad but we should at least see the
difference when we just set it to
perspective i think
um so if i set this to perspective yeah
there we go disappears okay
so um at the moment by default with the
perspective projection on i think
uh our square should actually be like at
the same position as our camera because
the z coordinate is not
you know it's zero so that camera i
think um
but uh that's why we're not seeing
anything
but if we quickly fill this stuff in so
again this is gonna work exactly the
same way right
except the only difference is that um
i'm actually going to just
hurry this up by changing
orthographic to um
perspective in the selection
and then obviously
[Music]
um and then near and fast the same okay
that's it i think um
the only difference is the yeah well
that's it actually
make sure we call recalculate projection
and i think that's good
um now can we move the square backwards
though that's the thing
i don't know if we can do we have no
i've got xyz transform i think
we should be able to right yeah we do
so if we get the camera entity here um
[Music]
uh we can still obviously change the
ortho size if i switch to perspective
um oh vertical five is zero point seven
eight
five oh we're still on ortho size
wait what but that is the vertical five
why is it
is it in radians oh it's in radians
my bad okay um so
this let's rename this because we didn't
rename it
so this is the vertical file i'll just
do a lowercase
vertical file and then we want to
convert that into degrees and then
back into radians because we want to
deal with it in degrees
um that should be better
okay so um there's our camera let's make
this a little bit bigger
perspective 45 good
and then if we actually move our camera
backwards by increasing our position
um you can see that we can see this and
as we move as we keep moving the camera
backwards
it goes further away we've done it 3d
rendering
inside hazel the game engine series i
mean amazing i know i know that you guys
want a 2d but
here's a here's a curveball we're now
doing 3d stuff okay that's pretty cool
right and then obviously same with the
green square we can actually push that
back in space or forward in space
and you can see that depending on our z
position
this is actually now getting smaller
because we're of course using uh
orthographic projection
sorry perspective projection if we go to
our different camera
um i guess we won't see anything because
uh where is our green square green
square is not
in here has to be
like that right why are we not seeing
this that's oh there it is
okay and then obviously if we switched
over from camera and maybe this camera
is like
way further away then you can see that
the different sizes and stuff even
though technically it's quite the same
size and we're doing we're using
completely different
types of projection okay so if we had
multiple
squares which we could have um then you
would see the difference actually let's
set that up quickly that'll be fun
so let's add another square if we go
into
uh where is our square entity uh is it
easy for us to just
we should add a function to duplicate a
square that'll be nice
but um let's add another square
square two red square
um we'll make this one red
uh and then
i think that's really all we need right
because it automatically creates a
transform
that's pretty easy nice and easy to
create these entities they'll be they'll
be in the same position i think
which could be interesting um but if we
move the red square out of the way
see this is the fun this is where the
fun begins um if you can call
if you can call it that so if we go to
perspective and we just pull this a
little bit further away
if we get the red square and we you know
move it either closer or further or
whatever
and if we switch cameras um then let's
move that camera
this is the clip space entity camera
right
oh um let's increase our far clip far
clip um
then you can see that these cameras
these squares are
exactly the same size right with all the
graphic projection
but if we go to perspective projection
they're different sizes
because one is further away and that is
the difference between perspective and
orthographic projection if you're new to
graphics
but also a really good test of our
cameras working properly
now we haven't set up the primary camera
control or anything like that i don't
know if it's worth doing that just
because
um actually it is
it is because it does work i don't think
it works in hazel dev but we've made it
work right because i think that's what
that's what we do here i think we
yeah there it is primary camera so if
it's if it's primary camera then we
yeah we basically have a little toggle
for it so what we want to do
is um if we go into uh scene hierarchy
panel which is where
where we are anyway then um
what what should we have this first or
last or
hmm i don't know i guess we'll have it
first
we can just do i am gooey checkbox um
and then this will be
basically uh primary and this will just
be
um camera component
camera component dot primary and we'll
also add in a
fixed aspect ratio which
is more of like a a um
orthographic thing to be honest
i might add that in at the end here
and i think that that that should maybe
work now
now the thing is obviously we are
manipulating this using other editor ui
and that's
totally fine so like if we look at um
this camera it's our primary camera
camera entity clip space camera is not
our primary camera
and then if i toggle this this goes on
right so we now have a way to see that
but we can also actually
uh toggle that off um now we've got no
primary cameras in our scene that's why
we're not seeing anything
and then we can decide to like turn this
on because this will only affect stuff
when it actually
like gets changed something else changes
it it doesn't read it and respond
um and then uh yeah so that's it uh it's
bothering me that this is in a different
place but i guess it doesn't matter
uh and then fixed aspect ratio um if we
have an autographic camera like this and
we turn fixed aspect ratio on
i think that no matter what we resize it
to you can see that it's going to
keep to its own aspect ratio um which is
probably not
necessarily what we want but if we
change that and then we resize
you can see that it works properly so
that's what that does but
yeah that's the camera component now
fully functional
hope you guys enjoyed this video as i
desperately trying to find the right
overlay
um hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please don't forget to hit the
like button below and if you aren't on
twitch then don't forget to follow the
stream
shout out to jack jackson jack jackson
for subscribing
uh during the recording of the stream of
the stream of the stream
um don't forget that you can also help
support the series by going to
patreon.com and then you'll also get
access to hazel dev which is what i
showed earlier
the more advanced version of hazel and
of course you'll be supporting
hazel's development as well as the
development of
this whole series next time according to
our roadmap it looks like we are going
to continue on with
um other ui stuff probably like the
sprite rendering ui maybe revisiting the
tag ui and getting uh
all of the rest of the components
basically sorted out so we can have a
more complete way to actually build
build stuff inside hazel and then from
then onwards we also want to be able to
create
like add and remove entities and stuff
like that using the ui
so that's really when we'll be able to
stop using the code hopefully
and start actually building things
inside hazel thank you all for watching
and i will see you next time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you